Rosalia you are in the building
congratulations eight nominations
does the novelty wear off or does it
still feel special like if it was your
first nomination no it always feels
special it's always a blessing so I
never take anything for granted yeah
yeah of course this year though you get
to share this night with your man Rao
who also has eight nominations does that
make a night like that even more special
getting to share with him of course
because you know something like this if
you are able to share it with people
that you love I'm here with him with my
sister like to me this makes it even
like the motion bigger everything it
feels much better and I enjoy it more
yeah you know he said you guys have
crazy chemistry do you guys Inspire each
other and your music I think definitely
definitely really I think that we share
a lot of time together so that always
gets reflected somehow you know in what
we do of course I gotta congratulate you
on your tour because it was amazing
everybody was talking about it we also
went viral from chewing that gum did you
ever think you become a meme no I was
just rehearsing I was just rehearsing
with my dancers and I was just you know
like having fun I was just like doing it
so they would laugh and I realized that
they were actually like laughing so much
so I was like okay let me do it yeah so
I put it on the joke like that like
simple like that look at it let's do it
together ready oh okay okay
iconic